who was our special guest who spotted
rook takes h7 immediately well we have
Grandmaster Susan Polgar recent u.s.
chess Hall of Fame inductee with
Murray's well once a champion always a
champion and this lady sees booms like
this in her sleep literally but we would
be listening accolades for ours if we
started listening hers Susan the hall of
famer recent Hall of Famer for all the
great things that she has done in chess
I'm gonna hold off and I'll list them
one by one as we continue the interview
Susan first of all welcome to the show
thank you Frank congratulations on the
Hall of Fame in joining the the
induction into the Hall of Fame you've
been a world champion many times you
have coached champions as well you
became a grandmaster the first woman to
do so officially you you want Olympic
medals with your sisters you're part of
this trio everything came together at
the Hall of Fame ceremony and you give
such an impassioned speech tell us what
that meant to you oh it was very very
touching very very nice it was a
recognition for not just my achievements
I felt but also for everybody who helped
me along the way because it was a
teamwork starting with my parents who
sacrificed so much for me being able to
follow my passion and my dream my
sisters or my coaches my friends
including yourself I remember when we
were training for my upcoming World
Championship but while I was already in
New York and all the friends and the
fans you know it's really a recognition
to to everybody who helped me along the
way and you have coached so many great
teams as well just passing on that
legacy to the next generation as well as
your Spice Cup and all girls nationals
what are those efforts mean to you now
that you are not playing anywhere it
means the world to me since I retired
from competitive chess myself I really
enjoy sharing my knowledge and
experience with the next generation the
students at Webster University as well
as throughout my foundations events with
girls especially dear to my
this woman's chess and it's really
heartwarming for me to see that over the
past since 2003 about 15 years or so
since I started my foundation the growth
of women's chest is is really noticeable
as we can see the Jennifer use and
magnifying and Carissa heap and and and
other young wonderful talented players
I remember them then they they were so
little tiny girls and back they came and
they learned through the was
Invitational that my foundation has
hosted for 15 years already coming up
near 16 and it's really nice to see how
far they went and I look forward to to
see them go even much further you said
about 15 years ago curse is only 15
Jennifer is 17 I mean they were just
starting out they don't even know a time
that the struggles that you and other
women before you had speak a little bit
about that change that has happened in
the climate from women's chess how wood
suffered in the past and now it's
starting to finally change right well I
remember the days when I was a
competitive player a young girl and it
was a shock to people in those days when
I would beat a male player or a male
master or eventually grandmaster and to
the degree that some opponents even
refused to shake hands or vibe the
pieces of the board so that's that
really was not easy and then a lot of
other challenges among the along the
years but things have somewhat improved
of course they the good news is I got
them used to it right they enough
opponents lost and eventually my to my
sisters and other women players that
it's no longer a shocking surprise if a
girl a woman beats a man it's okay if
you're rated your strong player you beat
another strong player or a lower rated
player it's normal regardless of gender
so that is certainly an accomplishment
that although I have to say it hasn't
yet fully changed and I have to say even
as a coach that has been
numerous cases when some of the coaches
of other teams or program directors
wouldn't shake my hands when we won so
it is still a work in progress but we
still but of course we made significant
progress also just absolutely ridiculous
remember I had the honor of playing your
sister Sophia in a match and we drew
three to three that was one of the
highlights of my experience as a
competitor but now as you said these
young girls they are playing like beasts
and seven out of 12 youngsters in the
tournament of this caliber have you seen
that anywhere in the world where the
veterans are outnumbered by the kids no
it's really impressive it's really
impressive and I think it's really a
combination of things how the chess
culture has changed in the United States
in front of my eyes
since I'm here I'm proud to say that I
have started a little bit this whole
revolution back when I moved here and I
started to make specific efforts in
changing that I remember when I started
in fact the whole reason I started my
foundation was that there weren't any
any all-girl tournaments except the US
Women's Championship that's it one event
a year and everything else it's all
mixed and I think it was really
important for the girls get that extra
encouragement and opportunities through
those events and I'm so pleased to see
now that there are in addition to my
foundations event there are a number of
other wonderful similar events that that
give opportunities to young girls and I
think it's definitely part of the reason
for the growth and of course the rack
Sanjana Singh field is just amazing all
the support they have been giving the
chest and also the blue girls and
women's as well so I think it's the
whole carpet culture it's not only the
specifics that necessarily just the
events that are happening but also the
prospects that the young players today
see compared to 20-30 years ago not just
girls but boys as well they see a much
better perspective staying in chess even
as a player or even in other capacities
as a coach or commentator a writer or
so it has the Justine has really changed
I think in front of avocado and eyes
absolutely beautifully said well
encapsulated before I let you go we want
to give you credit for this position
because as I said once a champion always
a champion you you must get excited when
you saw that move rook eight seven and
pointed out to us as you walked in we
can bring up that position on the screen
with Jennifer you that possibility of
rook takes eight seven right now Susan's
just waltzed in and said hey we're Kate
Shepherd what's up with that that's a
great line what does that feeling good
when you're coaching a student and
you're sitting on the side and you go
hey wait a minute you better play this
move do you ever feel like the
competitive juices start flowing again
yeah sometimes I still feel the
butterflies you know just as much as I
used to when I used to play when some of
our students play an important game and
I see the right move and I hope you'll
find it or she finds it and you know
usually they do but once in a while they
don't so it's like well your team has
won seven national championships Webster
has I'm sure your team is seeing some
good moves back thank you so much for
joining us so we are impressed by
everything you've done in the world of
chess and continue to do and I've heard
that the move was played rook eight
seven five yes your lips to Jennifer's
ears move on the board
Susan ProGuard ladies and gentlemen one
of the great ambassadors of our sports
one of the great ground breakers in our
sport and continues to do so at the very
highest level thank you for joining us
thank you